josé cardoso disse
aprendi a cantar sem professor
com a graça de deus ou completo você vem
me chamado de analfabeto exibir no
diploma de doutor no congresso que foi o
competidor o ganhar de você de 10 a 0
meu amigo você muito sinceros eu deixar
de cantar não sou feliz ser poeta eu sou
porque deus quis
ec doutor eu não sou porque não quero
mande a fortaleza
eu venho de alto santo no sertão do
ceará e foi bem lá e foi de lá que uma
vez assistindo a cantoria de viola e um
bebê bo e pediu moto que ele disse
quanto mais o nordestino mas tem orgulho
de ser
aí eu fiz um poema que diz sou gibão do
vaqueiro socos curso rapadura sou vida
difícil e dura
sou nordeste brasileiro sou cantador e
violeiro só alegria ao chover só doutor
sem saber lei sou rico sem ser grande
sino
quanto mais o nordestino mas tem orgulho
de ser terra de cultura viva chico
anysio gonzagão de renato aragão ariano
e patativa gente boa
criativa isso só me dá prazer
por isso hoje aqui no tek fortaleza eu
quero dizer muito obrigado ao destino
porque quanto mais sou nordestino mas
tem orgulho de ser de novo meu povo
eu sou paulo bessa eu venho de alto
santo uma cidade pequenininha aqui no
sertão do ceará pequenininha mesmo que
todo mundo é primo de 18 mil habitantes
e lá eu sou conhecido como na vida dessa
bateria é assim que eu me apresente em
todo canto o método é sapateiro porque
cidade pequena tem essa peculiaridade
toda cidade pequena a gente é conhecido
pela família
não é assim que é do interior aqui sabe
que é desse jeito fulano é tão enfim do
manel do leite
geralmente é desse jeito é ir lá no meu
caso eu sou bravo dessa pateiro ngal
neta dessa bateu e lá tem até um caso
muito emblemático de antônio de nilce
nilce é a mãe dele então anton é um
pedreiro antônio e nilce que é pai de
curling carrington e the news mais
parece uma palavra só
e não é carlin e anton edenilson não tem
vírgula não tem espaço é carlinhos não
tão de nilce
e quando você pensa que não pode piorar
nas gustavo gostava de carlo antonini
wilson quatro gerações que gustavo está
a cargo de antónio são quatro gerações o
nome do menino então eu sou neto de 10
sapateiro e foi lá fui lá de alto santo
que eu aprendi também a uma poesia que
eu me tornei um fazedor de poesia como o
meu grande mestre e o maior poeta
popular desse país patativa do assaré e
eu com 14 anos uma professora me passa
um trabalho de escola eu não conhecia
poesia e eu fui falar sobre a vida de
patativa eu me apaixonei e disse eu
quero ser assim o canto da unha do dedo
mindinho de patativa do assaré
eu descobri que eu também podia fazer
isso que eu podia ser mais um guerreiro
na luta pela cultura na luta por um
resgate cultural do nosso nordeste mato
sim besta não tem essa filosofia de vida
não nego minhas raízes não nego minhas
origens e digo muito o cabra que nega
suas raízes nega a si mesmo e quem
esquece de onde veio não sabe para onde
vai
então não esqueço de onde eu vim matuto
sim besta não passei a escrever poesia
de cordel com 14 anos mas eu tinha que
ganhar dinheiro que a gente tem muito
isso né
a completar 18 anos acaba tendo que
ganhar dinheiro e poesia
o dinheiro não vem e aí eu fui fazer
faculdade de análise de sistemas
uma coisa que não tinha nada a ver com a
outra
até aí eu me tornei em alto santo o
menino que sabia bowling computador
porque em todos e em toda cidade pequena
também tem aquele menino que desenrolado
então tudo era comigo nem sabia bullying
computador eu me tornei uma espécie de
bill gaytten e alto santo
revolucionou o mundo da informática né
se tornou o tipo vale do silício
lá em alto santo inclusive na na grande
alto santo nas regiões metropolitanas
alta ontem 18 mil habitantes mas tem a
zona rural que o chang e região
metropolitana
a grande alto santo que me tornei o
menino sabia bullying computador e isso
foi muito importante para o meu
desenvolvimento e para a minha luta hoje
pela cultura de associar elementos
coisas que teoricamente não tem nada a
ver com cultura popular poesia matuta
com informática tecnologia e tal e eu
fui ver aqui hoje
lá na frente que tem tudo a ver
foi o que aconteceu não confunda
interior com inferior
eu tenho isso como um mantra ninguém
confunda interior o inferno ou quem é do
interior não inferior a ninguém
a informação
com a chegada da internet
eu que vivi meus 30 anos nas cidades em
escondida lá no sertãozinho a informação
com a chegada da internet ela chegava de
forma muito democrática e rápida na
mesma velocidade que chega aos grandes
centros com um computador conectado à
internet o cabo estava em alto santo ele
tinha o mesmo acesso às informações as
mesmas informações do cabo que está aqui
em fortaleza em são paulo e nova york
ela é mundial ela é global agora com a
chegada das mídias sociais das redes
sociais
aí houve uma revolução porque porque nós
do interior zin a informação não só
chegava
ela podia sair também
o que nós passamos a gerar conteúdo
foi a democratização das redes
então acaba tava lá no interior ele
também podia falar
ele não só ouvia e foi aí que eu unindo
minha paixão pela cultura nordestina foi
um lindo
a literatura de cordel e algum
conhecimento em informática que eu criei
depois de ter me tornado o bill gates e
ao santo - a bíblia em computador
eu tive um sonho de criar um movimento
pra reunir um milhão de pessoas para
defender divulgar e fazer um resgate da
cultura popular nordestina através de
que brown e através da internet
pra mim era de graça e eu tenho um sonho
que eu não tinha dinheiro mas um
sonhador nunca pobre velho um sonhador
não quer pobre eu não tinha dinheiro e
não tinha amigos influentes
eu não tinha conhecimentos técnicos mas
eu tenho um computador na minha mão em
cima da mesa da cozinha de casa
eu disse eu vou reunir um milhão de
pessoas pra defender o povo nordestino e
tantos e tantos casos de preconceito que
estava acontecendo na internet
principalmente na época de um processo
histórico e doloroso sofrido pelo nosso
povo de sair lá pra fora e ser tão
agredido
logo nós nordestinos que somos um povo
tão receptivo tão carinhoso
você chega aqui rapaz e pergunta o papa
vem de fora pedem informação o cearense
no ensina não ele leva você lá então por
que a gente é tão agredido eu digo não
pô
a gente tem que fazer alguma coisa foi
quando surgiu um projeto chamado nação
nordestina criou o projeto para fazer um
resgate para aflorar a nordestinidade em
tantos e tantos novos destinos
espalhados pelo mundo não só os que
estão aqui
o projeto chegou a um milhão de
seguidores têm um impacto social e
cultural e mais de 20 milhões de pessoas
por mês vai resgatando a autoestima
resgatando uma cultura que estava
esquecida e de forma paradoxal porque
você usar justamente
o novo à internet a tecnologia que é
apontada como uma espécie de vilã num
processo de esquecimento das raízes
porque as pessoas desaprenderam menino
não solta mais um peão porque estava
mexendo no computador
o menino solta mais uma pipa porque está
no celular
então por que não usar esse vilão como
aliado para estimular a valorização das
raízes num público jovem que a maioria
do público de internet e foi com o sonho
vai a gente alcançou esse objetivo e aí
o que foi que aconteceu
o projeto ganhou muita força mas muita
força mesmo e aí eu essencialmente como
eu disse para vocês eu sou poeta
cordelista eu escrevo poesia de cordel
desde os 14 anos
e aí eu parei e pensei se a cultura
nordestina de forma global teve uma
aceitação e um carinho tão grande nas
mídias sociais com o projeto nacional da
china porque não cordel também uma
manifestação cultural tão rica e tão
bonita então vulgarizada tão
desvalorizada onde as pessoas até têm um
muita gente se liga nisso acha que a
literatura de cordel é uma poesia
simples e pelo contrário
a literatura de cordel é a poesia mais
complexa de se construir exigem rima
métrica tem uma série de regras mas ela
nunca foi tão valorizada e eu disse não
eu vou honrar eu vou honrar o nome de
patativa do assaré
vou honrar o nome de manoel xudu o zé da
luz e tantos e tantos poetas que nunca
tiveram a oportunidade de usar o poder
das redes sociais para levar a
literatura de cordel mais longe em casa
peguei um celular a gravar a literatura
de cordel uma poesia essencialmente
narrada não foi feita para ser escrito e
guardada e eu com o celular legal vou
gravar agora meus cordéis e vou publicar
na internet
até me falar cara na internet não tem
ninguém
consumir isso não e talvez eu fiquei só
perder seu tempo levou a produção não é
tão cara sou eu e meu celular eu sou
roteiristas ou o câmera o editor
então quem é que eu tenho a perder e o
cordel
o cordel é tudo até poesia chico anysio
disse que o humor é tudo até engraçado
eu de cordão é tudo até poesia
o cordel é muito global você pode falar
de tudo você pode falar de amor você
pode falar de saudade
você pode falar dos pais da mãe de shift
você pode falar de política
você pode falar qualquer coisa e aí eu
estava lá em alto santo e uma invasão
cara uma invasão a chegada das drogas
nas pequenas cidades no interior
isso é uma problemática tão grande que a
gente ver cidades pacatas e de repente
com a chegada das drogas de tráfego e
tal a cidade se torna violenta
aí a gente conversando uma vez foi o
primeiro cordel que eu gravei e postou
na internet onde eu fiz um protesto
contra as drogas que será que o povo vai
gostar disso porque eu pensei um rapaz
com tanta mulher bonita irá retirar os
cabos cheirando cocaína está um cordel
eu peguei meu celular votei aqui disse
o cordel da cocaína versus um cheiro no
cangote
eu gravei disse junto e da skillus de
flor 20 perfume dos fortes
o minimilho animale de azar outra a
glote
nada disso se compara com essa
fragrância errada que a mulher tem o
cangote
é por isso que eu me admiro quando eu
vejo no esquina um cabo cheirando pó se
esquecem da menina desses besta que
inventa de sacaba pelas venta com essa
tal de cocaína com tanta mulher bonita
no mundo para cheirar éboli cipó no mato
toma um banho vai se arrumar se
desapegar sinnott e vai procurar um
forró no cangote a cheirar
muito obrigado obrigado pessoal e aí eu
gravei este vídeo com o celular e postou
na internet teve mais de um milhão de
vigilantes de visualizações passaram a
ser exibido em escolas
palestrante que fazem palestras contra
as drogas declamando essa poesia eu vi
olha o poder que o cordel tem então vou
falar de tudo e passei a gravar vídeos
para gravar vídeos com cordel e tal e
foi se espalhando esses vídeos uma
literatura de cordel já tem mais de 30
milhões de visualizações
foi o que aconteceu com a minha vida
você pegar uma poesia tipicamente matuta
onde na maioria das vezes ela morre nas
pequenas feiras comporta declamando e
cair moedas no prato
porque a poesia não é comercial ea
televisão viu esses meus vídeos
televisão vi os vídeos e eu fui fazer
uma participação falar sobre minha
poesia sobre a cultura do nordeste no
programa encontro com o fátima bernardes
e aquilo foi a cara do brasil
hoje eu faço parte do elenco fixo do
programa semanalmente toda sexta feira
no programa encontro com fatia não é
porque é pra vocês fátima com farinha
eu tô num encontro com farinha e lá eu
ganhei um quadro chamado poesia com
rapadura onde todas as sextas sobre um
dos temas do programa eu desenvolvo
escrevo um cordel e declama e isso o
poder disso é muito grande de você pegar
uma poesia que nunca teve espaço uma
manifestação cultural que nunca teve
espaço na grande mídia e tem a
oportunidade de levar a milhões e
milhões e milhões de pessoas
representando representando não poeta
mas representando uma manifestação
cultural uma cultura que nasce local mas
com potencial para ser global com
potencial para ser global então hoje é
fico muito honrado em poder disseminar
essa arte que é tão rica e que hoje sim
hoje chegou até as pessoas e aí
bráulio semente plantada sim eu sou o
cimento e do trabalho de patativa eu me
tornei poeta porque eu conheci a arte de
patativa eu disse eu quero sair daqui
também eu quero ser mais um guerreiro na
luta pela cultura popular nordestina e
hoje
hoje é uma felicidade e uma honra e eu
até me emociono quando eu falo disso
está começando também a plantar uma
semente aqui
é um vídeo de natália cinco anos
declamando o poema que eu abrir aqui eu
não gosto brasileiro só cantava o
violeiro só alegria ao fui ver o show do
tom
sem saber nem sou ricos em chegar ao fim
quanto mais tolo destino à nova york
disse a minha cabeça chata no meu estado
a estado do nosso solo rachado
essa gente mal tratada quase sempre
injustiçada
acostumada a sofrer por isso nesse papel
6 ou feliz bom vinho quanto mais somos
um destino mas teu nome de casa de
cultura viva ficou nível ronaldão e
renato aragão ariano e batata ativa pea
que doa reativa e só me dá prazer por
lixo e tá muito exigente não obrigado ao
destino quanto mais sou nordestino mas
terra rubim
diariamente eu recebo vídeos de crianças
do brasil todo declamando cordel e aí
sim eu sinto que eu também estou
plantando a semente e eu já penso
natália vai plantar sementes e vai
colher lá na frente
então eu quero dizer pra vocês deixam a
última mensagem em forma de cordel sobre
a vida onde eu disse só eu sei cada
passo por mim dado nessa estrada
esburacada que a vida passei coisas que
até mesmo deus duvida
eu fiquei triste cap ogu aperriado porém
nunca me sentir motivado eu me agarra
sempre uma mão amiga e de forças minha
alma era unida pois do céu a voz de deus
dizia assim sua busca chu metros pés
confie em mim vá pra luta que eu cuido
das feridas
vão pra luta que deus cuida das feridas
muito obrigado muito obrigado muito
obrigado pessoal